What I want to do is work through the,
the slides here and
the base filter, getting us, to how
we come up with our new belief okay?
So this is just our definition before,
that the belief is the probability about
the current state, given everything
including, the current measurement,
so we're going to use the Bayes
rule that we just showed
that says we can swap that around by
putting in the likelihood and the prior.
And the prior is just Xt without
the Zt over here, right?
That was our prediction
about what Xt was and
this is this likelihood model, right?
This is just our sensor
likelihood model.
What's the likelihood
of getting that value?
All right.
Well our sensor independence that
we talked about before says,
if you have this state, xt,
then none of this stuff matters and
it's just p of zt, given xt.
That's sensor independence.
All right, so here we are.
So the next thing we can do is
remember we talked about this before.
This notion of total probability.
The way we do a prediction.
Okay, for
any given xt what we have to do is say,
well, what's our prediction of
all the possible xt minus 1.
What, why are there many of them?
Well All the possible x's at t minus 1.
If we take all the probability okay,
that we would,
we sum up over all those possibilities,
and here, you notice what we said was,
what's the probability of
going to xt from xt minus 1,
times this probability of xt minus 1,
summed up over all of
those xt minus ones.
That will be the, the prediction,
that will be the prior.
But this value, actually,
can get made much smaller.
Because, notice.
That has this term and that term.
Because remember the Markovian property
says that if we have XT minus one and
we want to predict XT all this other
stuff doesn't matter except the action.
Right.
So, basically you get me where I thought
I was before and what action you did,
I can tell you about where I think I
am now, and that's what this
Markovian step is right there.
One more time, flies up, wow, beautiful.
Okay, keep going.
All right.
Well, now, actually,
we're pretty much done, and
now everything is beautiful and
color coded, all right?
We start here, right.
This value right here,
that's just our belief about all
the xs at the last time step.
So that's written here.
So now we're already looking at
a recursive algorithm, right,
because on the left-hand side,
we have the belief of xt.
On the right-hand side,
we have the belief of xt minus one, so.
This is a induction, remember we
talked about tracking induction.
This is induction formula that goes
from your belief that T minus one
to your belief at T.
When you integrate or
sum overall the possible xt minus ones,
these are your predictions
before taking the measurement.
So this is just like we did
with the Kalman before.
To make your prediction, what you do is
you take your belief about where things
were, you pump it through your dynamics
and you add it onto your uncertainty.
And then what this is showing is,
to get our new belief, okay,
we just multiply that by
the likelihood of the measurement.
Remember it's not the It's not
your probability of where you
are given the measurement.
It's how likely would this
measurement have been
if that had been the particular x.
And then we can worry about
this normalization later.
That's how we get
the belief at new time t.